direction saint gilles jérémy attyasse
connu sur notre île dans le monde du
surf comme le directeur de compétition
nous fait découvrir le spot des brisants
aller jérémy c'est à toi de nous donner
une petite leçon sur les vagues entre de
compet pas le sport des brisants
setchine gauche dans l'ouest de l'île
qui se trouve à côté du port de saint
gilles et c'est pour ça qu'on l'appelle
aussi l'a dit une gauche très technique
qui permet beaucoup le perfectionnement
dans le surf et surtout
ce qui est un peu dangereux ici c'est le
rif en dessous qui est à fleur d'eau
donc plus on avance sur la vague et
moins ado donc faut faire vachement
attention
c'est un spot plutôt pour les gens qui
savent surfer il ya beaucoup de pick sur
le spot on dénombre trois flics ou on
peut surfer le pic du fonds le troisième
pic pour exclusivement les bodyboardeurs
c'est une gauche qui nous permet de
tubes et d'envoyer des grossman aérienne
mais y'a vraiment vraiment pas d'eau
vers le deuxième clic pour que tout le
monde s'ils veulent fumer ou pas et puis
le dernier pic où on permet de
d'effectuer des manoeuvres
la panoplie des manoeuvres du cher
finalement le roller le flotteur les
riads et si tu ne vas tellement
technique
tu permets fait de venir faire des
entraînements ici c'est vraiment génial
et si le spot est comme peu fréquentée
mais en dénombre comme des locaux qui
viennent assez régulièrement dont les
bodyboardeurs les meilleurs de l'île
viennent s'entraîner sur le troisième
qui est ils sont très friands parce que
c'est une vague très radical est
parfaite pour eux en fait pour pouvoir
s'exprimer
le dimanche il ya les petits habitués
qui viennent sur fait en famille parce
que commis à la plage juste à côté
les parents peuvent rester sur le bord
les enfants au surf et c'est assez
convivial dans l'eau on attend vraiment
sa priorité c'est assez convivial et ça
fait plaisir de venir chercher ici